une rare mobilisation pour des élections
locales
il y à des courses pour tous les sièges
en jeu une première et 4 million de hong
kong et plus de la moitié de la
population se sont inscrits pour voter
un record tout cela était difficilement
imaginable il ya encore quelques mois
mais ça c'était avant que la
contestation ne perdure encore une vague
qui a incité ce jeune diplômé en
sciences sociales et tant d'autres à
faire le saut en politique dans l'espoir
que la colère des derniers mois les
demandes de réformes politiques
la volonté de défendre le territoire
contre les gérances de pékin rapporte
gros
dans les urnes c'est loin d'être gagné
car la population de hong kong est
divisé les politiciens pro-gouvernement
mise d'ailleurs sur ce qu'ils appellent
la majorité silencieuse
cette candidate à sa réélection
mais même de l'avant les violences
perpétrées par les manifestants les plus
radicaux pour demander à l'électorat de
faire confiance à son camp pour
restaurer l'ordre et préserver encore le
messager qui résonne chez bien des
résidents
ébranlé par les scènes de destruction
des dernières semaines est inquiète et
prédit une défaite des pro pékin chaque
vote va compter pressent seront qu'un
gay pro démocratie
j'espère que nous ferons la différence
dit-il
avec ce scrutin local habituellement
sans grand enjeu
chacun des camps veux voir ce que
privilégie les hong kong et la stabilité
ou la prospérité est vantée par les uns
ou encore la défense des droits et
libertés promue par les autres c'est ce
que souhaite cet opposant de longue date
c'est ce qu'il voudrait faire comprendre
à la chef de l'exécutif qui a une âme au
pouvoir central apic un sort aux mains
du peuple dit il
ici aux libéraux radio canada hong kong